und jetzt wird's noch mal richtig
emotional die Verleihung des Preises auf
den auch in diesem Jahr so viele so
unglaublich hart hingearbeitet haben
ohne es zu merken herzlich willkommen
zu der goldene Vollpfosten
2023 herzlichen guten Abend lieben
Leuten endlich ist es wieder soweit der
goldene vollpsten und für mich als ein
netzreporterin natürlich in riesenehre
diesen Preis hier live im Sterbenden
Medium Fernsehen verleihen zu dürfen und
dann auch noch neben ein quasi sterbende
Moderator vielen herzlichen Dank ARD ja
ich freue mich auch kommen wir nun zu
unserem ersten Preisträger die Deutsche
Bahn Ende vom Witz auf
Wiedersehen haben Sie gemerkt her ich
habe so getan als wä ich fertig weil
schon wenn man B sagt lachen die Leute
ja ja weil es ein so wahnsinnig
schlechtes Verkehrsmittel ist das alle
immer so vololl scheiße ja ja ich hatte
die gmechanik schon verstanden okay ja
2023 was für ein Katastrophenjahr für
die Bahn aber dafür mit einer tollen
Schlusspointe der Vorstand der Deutschen
Bahn soll für das vergangene Jahr
offenbar Bonuszahlungen von insgesamt
fast 5 Millionen Euro
erhalten 5 Millionen Boni für nur noch
66% bei Fernzügen in den ersten 10
Monaten des Jahres dabei fängt
Verspätung bei denen erst nach 6 Minuten
an und ausgefallene Züge werden
praktischerweise gar nicht mitgerechnet
ja und bei Kundenzufriedenheit hat die
Bahn schlechter abgeschnitten als je
zuvor in ihrem ganzen Leben aber ich
finde Kunden werden eh überschätzt weil
ich sag mal Züge fahren ja auch ohne
Kunden aber ja ein Kunde fährt nicht
ohne Zug denken sie da mal drüber nach
jeder dritte Zug bei der Bahn kommt zu
spät sagt die Bahn selbst neuer
verspätungsrekord massive
Einschränkungen ein echter
Investitionsstau nach Jahren des
Stillstands die Gestrandeten Fahrgäste
ratlos Bahnfahren wird zur Nervenprobe
der sogenannte deutschlandtakt der
Deutschen Bahn wird erst ja sie hören
richtig im Jahr
2070 kommen mich interessiert das nicht
bis D bin ich
tot ich bin dann gerade mal
104 in dem Alter kann man nur noch bei
den Stones Mitsingen Stones Verst du ich
verstehe gerade nicht was er sagt aber
egal denn nun würden wir sehr gerne den
Pfosten für die Bahn überreichen aber
wie Sie sehen habe ich leider kein weil
wir so eben erfahren haben der Pfosten
ist mit sein ICE leider am Dienstag in
henwestfallen liegen geblieben ja er
schickt uns dieses Foto und fragt ob die
heute schon ihm ein flexbus bezahlt auf
keinen Fall auf gar keinen Fall kommen
wir stattdessen lieber zu unserem
nächsten Preisträger Robert habbeck ja
was nein nicht den den habe ich früher
geliebt ich schwöre der war mit Abstand
der beste bei boysohn wirklich ja er war
maskulin aber auf so ein verletzliche
Art bestimmt bestimmt das jetzt aber gar
nicht der Punkt robert habbeck hat mit
einem hingehudelten wirklich wahnsinnig
schlecht gemachten
gebäudeenergiegesetetzt mit dafür
gesorgt dass statt Wärmepumpen wieder
mehr Gas und Ölheizung eingebaut werden
ja deswegen herzlichen Glückwunsch es
gibt für ihn von uns den goldenen
Vollpfosten und zwar als ein
Installateur verkleidet und schau mal ja
auf sein kleinen Blaumann sind lau
ölfleckchen weil er so viele Ölheizung
verbaut hat ja ja robert hat Fehler
gemacht aber er wurde auch fies gemobbt
vor allem auch in dieser
Sendung das deutsche Einfamilienhaus
wirchten wir wären darin sicher aber
dann kam er ein
Z komm vorbei D vi er steht vor deiner
Tür F se nimmt dir die Heizung Weg sie
haben dir das Fleisch weggenommen und
dein Geschlecht jetzt ist deine
Ölheizung
dran denn die Grünen hassen dich und
wollen dass du
frierst
nightm on östet nachts wenn der hab
kommt
ja Nightmare on
street Klassiker ja gut noch
erfolgreicher war genau ein Film und
zwar Bari der Film 1,4 Milliarden Dollar
an der Kinokasse für zugegebenermaßen
intelligent gemachte selbstironische
Unterhaltung man könnte aber auch sagen
für ein zwei Stunden langen Matel
Werbespot why ganz ehrlich ich hasse
Barbie weil ich durfte als Kind nur die
doof Petra haben ja meine Freundin immer
so guck mal Liss die neue Rainbow Magic
Barbie mit Einhorn und integrierten
Schminktisch und ich so ja sch ja schön
für dich meine kann nicht mal das Bein
so
abknicken anyway wo war ich ach ja
Barbie kackfilm und am Ende wird sie zu
Mensch warum sie hatte alles aber wegen
Barbie haben ganze Generationen von
Mädchen ein falsches Schönheitsideal
danke schön und dafür gibt es von uns
diesen
vpfosten ja wobei woran ich mich ja sehr
gerne erinnere ist Barbis Schwester
kennst du noch Skipper damals in den
70ern
es funktioniert nicht was mache ich
falsch ah vielleicht auf der anderen
Seite nein okay ja gut ein ein weiterer
weiterer herzlicher Glückwunsch zum
Vollpfosten geht heute Abend an Hubert
eiwanger meine Damen und Herren
selbstverständlich für Flugblatt Gate
schauen Sie mal der Posten hier sogar
mit Mini Schultasche voller
Flugblätter was steht da drauf nee das
lese ich nicht vor ja den Pfosten gibt's
aber gar nicht so sehr für den
17-Jährigen Hubert damals am
horstwesselgymnasium oder wie immer das
hieß sondern für die Reaktion des
Erwachsenen Hubert auf die Enthüllung
sie erinnern sich mein Bruder hat das
Flugblatt geschrieben und auf dem
Schulklo verteilt oh Gott du meine Güte
wer geht denn bitte aufs
Schulklo voll ekelhaft ich habe in den
kompletten 12 Jahren bis zuur aten
Klasse nicht einmal groß gemacht ich
schwöre aha jedenfalls gut zu wissen
dass man in Bayern selbst nach solchen
Enthüllungen ohne jede Demut und mit
ganz viel medienschälte
15,8% holen kann ja Oliver weil er ein
Original ist weil er redet wie normale
Menschen nur halt nicht auf Deutsch es
ist wie wenn Sie einen Fluss haben mit
10 m Breite und da sind die Krokodile
drin und sie sagen spring aufs andere
Ufer wenn er nicht rüber springen kann
muss man dort Trittsteine machen wo man
sicher rübergehen kann sonst wird man
von den Krokodil fen und diese
ampelregierung ist auf bestem Weg die
Bevölkerung Deutschlands an die
Krokodile zu
verfüttern wussten sie das ich wusste
das nicht dass Bayern so ein
krokodilprem hat ich weiß das liegt
bestimmt am Klimawandel ja höchst
wahrscheinlich so und zum guten Schluss
meine Damen und Herren reden wir bitte
noch mal über künstliche Intelligenz
Chat GPT das Thema des Jahres gefürchtet
aber auch gefeiert nicht zuletzt von
Schülern die nie wieder selber Aufsätze
schreiben müssen besser läuft dann beim
Aufsatz über den Künstler Friedensreich
Hundertwasser es ist sehr gut geworden
schöne Gliederung die auch wirklich Sinn
er giibt und ja ich fin sehr praktisch
muss ich ewig so Bücher lesen ja Bücher
hör bloß auf ich habe sogar mal einen
Roman gelesen der hieß die kleine rppe
nimmer es war so langweilig und außerdem
war das kaputt auf jeder Seite war ein
Loch
ja tatsächlich waren führende Experten
nicht nur vor immer mehr Fake News durch
KI sondern sogar vor einer möglichen
Vernichtung der Menschheit KI sei so
gefährlich wie Pandemie oder Atomkrieg
deshalb geht der letzte Vollpfosten des
Jahres an den homoapiens das einzige
Säugetier das unermütlich an seiner
eigenen Ausrottung arbeitet also ganz
ehrlich ich finde KI ist überschätzt
kann man sagen aber zur
Veranschaulichung habe ich extra für
heute Abend als be weiß mein eigenen
Avatar erschaffen sehen Sie selbst er
wurde gefüttert mit all meinem Wissen
aus mein Kopf und ich schwöre sie ist
trotzdem so
dumm hast du mich gerade dumm genannt
guck Dich mal selber an wie dumm du
aussiehst voll krass dumm und du meine
Güte ich kann nicht glauben dass i das
wirklich gerade gesagt hat ich meine
guck dir mal an wie sie aussieht sie hat
überhaupt kein
Geschmack ja ja bla blaa selber
überhaupt kein Geschmack gut ich würde
sagen ein intellektuelles Unentschieden
und das war die letzte heuteeschon des
Jahres jetzt kommt das ZDF Magazin Royal
wir sehen uns wieder am 26 Januar er
macht sehr sehr lange Pause weil er so
derartig faul ist es ist unglaublich
aber finde ich ganz gut das ist
wenigstens intelligente Unterhaltung
tschüss schöne feierertage egal ob mit
oder ohne bauen bis nächstes
[Applaus]
Jahr
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da
lasst ich habe die Schnauze
voll ja los lasst ein Abo
da